so you got to keep the toppings full
okay got it
I'm on top of that you don't fit in just
by yeah hey something that might be your
picture I'm walk Oh
Employee of the Year when does she work
but I was just wondering when she were
bruised me Oh
[Music]
congrat now here's the best part if I
work out of the other side is you get
all the free throw you want mm-hmm you
can't believe how delicious to do and
also fat-free thank God because my
boyfriend he just got back from his tour
in Afghanistan he's coming here to pick
me up he should be here in a minute I
haven't seen him in a year a whole year
you say hey hot song okay now give me
the extra shirt or anything they're
gonna be in there because these seem to
shrink uh-huh okay new oh I can't get
another that stuff I mean you should
have some it's free no I'm okay I'm I'll
have some later
I just got back from Afghanistan I'm
here looking for my girlfriend Latia no
it's not what it's me
apparently she doesn't work anymore
Thanks
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you